plutôt un an déjà depuis le début de la
guerre avec le lancement de l'offensive
russe sur l'Ukraine c'était le 24
février dernier on en parle aujourd'hui
avec Gulliver crack notre correspondant
dans le pays de passage à Paris bonjour
Gulliver et merci pour votre travail on
va tout d'abord revenir ensemble sur
l'actualité forte de cette semaine et
donc ce feu vert de l'Allemagne à la
livraison de Charles léopard 2 dont
l'Ukraine a fortement besoin et aussi
feu vert à la réexportation de ses chars
par les pays partenaires ces charmes
devraient être arrivés que fin mars en
tout cas ça suscite beaucoup d'espoir on
l'imagine auprès de la population
parce que vraiment on a vu dans le sujet
les soldats Ukrainiens disent qu'ils ont
cruellement besoin de nouveaux matériels
et notamment de char moderne et cela
avait été beaucoup beaucoup discuté
aussi dans les médias Ukrainiens tout le
monde était au courant et a suivi ce
feuilleton si vous voulez de Schultz le
chancelier allemand est-ce vous allez
donner les chars est-ce que les
américains puis finalement c'est là
c'est soldé par presque quelque chose
qui allait au-delà de leurs attentes
puisque les Américains ont dit
effectivement qu'ils vont fournir les
chars Abrams même si cela va prendre
plus longtemps que les chars léopard II
si je comprends bien et c'est justement
la question que beaucoup d'ukrainien se
posent est-ce que ce n'est pas trop tard
déjà parce qu'on voit que les Russes
commencent déjà à s'activer pour
peut-être une contre-offensive dans le
sud dans la région des aporisa notamment
on va voir mais ce que je voudrais dire
pour les largement c'est que
cette annonce à tout de même contribué
au moral général des Ukrainiens qui
restent très haut l'optimisme par
rapport au fait que le pays va finir tôt
ou tard par chasser les occupants russes
de son territoire et très très élevé il
est très rare de rencontrer des
Ukrainiens qui doutent en réalité il
doute de combien de temps ça va prendre
mais cela ne veut pas dire que les
Ukrainiens sont heureux un an de guerre
presque de guerre intense ça a un sur la
santé mentale de tout le monde c'est
absolument clair alors vous l'avez dit
bientôt un an de guerre Gulliver que
vous avez donc couvert aux côtés aussi
de nos envoyer spéciaux sur le terrain
peut-être votre regard sur cette année
écoulée des réflexions aussi sur votre
travail les difficultés aussi peut-être
que vous avez rencontré si je suis à
Paris en fait c'était justement aussi
pour discuter avec les collègues de
notre couverture de ce qu'on fait bien
de ce qu'on pourrait améliorer et aussi
plus généralement de la situation où on
se trouve avec cette guerre qui est
clairement aussi une guerre
d'information où nous avons d'un côté
une propagande russe qui est
vraiment construit de boutons blancs de
mensonges fait absolument de mensonge
qui raconte le monde à l'envers notre
collègue Hélène à Volochine le raconte à
l'antenne tous les toutes les semaines
avec des extraits de la télévision russe
et de l'autre côté les Ukrainiens qui
font aussi des efforts de communication
qui
ne raconte pas le monde à l'envers comme
font les Russes mais qui ne peuvent pas
non plus être crédités d'une crédibilité
de 200% si vous voulez on doit bien sûr
douter de ce que disent les deux côtés
parfois il est difficile d'avoir
confirmation de tel ou telle information
et puis le départ un peu plus
philosophique qu'on a dans cette
rédaction et je suppose dans les
rédactions de d'autres médias aussi
c'est face à une telle guerre une
invasion vraiment qui n'était pas
provoquée par un pays plus grand et puis
plus puissant d'un autre pays et les
crimes de guerre qu'on a vu les
massacres que qui ont été commises à
bout de chat les tortures moi-même j'ai
parlé avec des gens qui ont été torturés
par exemple dans la région de harkis
comment
raconter tout cela
ou est la neutralité où est
l'objectivité est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on devrait viser la
neutralité ou pas ou est-ce que plutôt
le mot clé que nous devons avoir c'est
l'objectivité d'être sûr que tout ce
qu'on dit c'est vrai tout en condamnant
les choses qui ont été qui qui sont à
mon avis éminemment condamnable c'est
donc quelques-unes un des difficultés à
couvrir cette guerre merci beaucoup
Gulliver pour votre témoignage